[Musique]
alors mon enfance en martinique avec mon
papa c'est beaucoup de souvenirs au
théâtre en salle de répétition
des kidnappings par les comédiens oui ça
arrive et ben ben on venait me chercher
à la crèche et n'était plus là parce que
la troupe de comédiens étaient déjà
passés emma avait récupéré donc
j'entends beaucoup d'anecdotes comme ça
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs au centre
dramatique régional ou bien goûter à de
la soif nouvelle qui est meuble
maintenant le top et à l'époque je
passais tous les mercredis après midi là
bas je prenais des cours de diction avec
aliou cissé c'était vraiment une
atmosphère magique et on était très
intégrée de dans
mon père c'est aussi sa grande
bibliothèque bibliothèque qui me
paraissait énorme j'avais l'impression
que c'était la tour de babel quoi et
beaucoup de références qui vont qui
m'ont marqué en fait dans mon parcours
je pense que c'est un homme très
intelligent très instruits qui m'a
beaucoup donné sur ça et qui m'a permis
de construire mon esprit d'analysé
c'est aussi le monsieur qui passait tout
le temps derrière moi pour dire tiens
par des cordes et jusqu'à maintenant
c'est resté tout comme l'articulation la
prononciation mais vraiment je pense que
avec les années qui sont pas assez ce
que j'aime le plus avec mon père c'est
que c'est vraiment la personne à qui je
peux parler de tout il a pas peur de
bons côtés sombres et je sais que je
peux tout lui dire lui aussi se confier
à moi et on a une relation assez
particulière comme ça oui ma porte
vraiment beaucoup donc voilà ces petits
souvenirs d'enfance quand je dis dans la
chanson à bâtir regard des poutres à
petare m'ont dit - s'enracine cada c'est
vraiment ce qu'ils m'ont apporté tous
les deux heures d'ancrage dans ma
culture dont mon identité dans ce que je
suis en tant que femme et en tant
qu'artiste par la suite parce que la
greta gerwig quoi donc on pas passer
hellip et non et je lui souhaite une
merveilleuse fête
lo